it's hard to find something everybody
agrees on
crunchy or smooth mac or pc
fries or onion rings fries but if
there's one financial instrument that
seems
universally beloved it's gotta be the
401k
everybody loves them people delay saving
for a home building an emergency fund or
even paying off high interest debt
in pursuit of this conquering hero the
tall
dark and handsome 401k my
hero there's a whole lot to love with
the 401k so saddle up and take a ride to
find out what makes this cowboy
the darling of investors everywhere
the year was 1980 and the revenue act of
1978 was finally going into effect
and deep in the bill was a tiny
provision section 401
subsection k largely overlooked section
401k
allowed employees to defer taxes on
bonuses
and stock options basically a way for
rich executives to make more
and pay less tax on it but everything
changed in 1981 when the irs ruled that
employees could also contribute from
their
salary this was music to employers
ears managing all those employee
pensions was expensive
complicated and downright risky maybe
this new fella
401k could replace the dusty old
pensions of our grandpappies
before long 401k fever was spreading
like
wildfire by 1996 401k accounts held over
a trillion dollars
how does it work fundamentally a 401k is
an employer-sponsored investment account
it lets you invest part of your paycheck
and receive a tax benefit for doing so
like company provided insurance programs
you have to
opt in to participate the most
attractive feature is the employer match
translation if you save for your future
the boss rewards you
with free money matching your
contribution dollar for dollar
up to a limit around half of 401ks offer
an employer match and this
free money can come to thousands of
extra dollars
then there's the sweet tax breaks
depending on the type of 401k
your contributions could be pre-tax
meaning it lowers your taxable income
for the year
or you can pay the tax now and allow
that money to grow
tax-free the more you save the less
taxes you pay
looking pretty spiffy over there mr 401k
oh and don't forget that your
contributions are being invested in
stock
and bond funds we have two cents
episodes about those if you're not sure
how they work
now you can just sit back and watch
compound interest
fatten your herd free money big tax
breaks and investment growth
what's not to love
[Music]
hold your horses there partner while the
401k has a lot going for it there are a
couple burrs under the saddle
like the risks of managing your own
investment portfolios instead of leaving
it to the professionals
as 401ks soared in popularity during the
80s and 90s
billions of dollars flowed into risky
sectors like tech stocks
and when things came crashing down like
they did twice in the 2000s
many working folks were left adrift like
a tumbleweed in the wind
and did you know that a mr 401k doesn't
work for free
a study by td ameritrade found that 73
of participants didn't know how much
their 401k
costs while 37 weren't aware that they
were paying fees at all
investment firms regularly rack up hefty
fees since
nobody's paying attention but the
average being around 1.4
and remember that juicy employer match
we mentioned earlier
well that might not end up being yours
thanks to
401k investing even though funds might
appear in your account they're
only yours once you become vested often
three to five years after you get hired
with the vast majority of millennials
only expecting to stay in a job for
a few years at the most that's a lot of
free money that
never gets collected
despite their perks and general
popularity 401ks have left a societal
legacy that's
well ugly see 401ks were originally
designed to be a
supplement to worker pensions for most
of the 20th century it was
common for workers to stay with a single
employer for most of their lives
and for that loyalty their company
offered a defined benefit pension for
the workers golden years
these plans offered steadiness and
security with the employer watching over
everyone's plans from the janitor to the
ceo
by their peak in 1980 38 of all
private sector workers had an employer
pension today
only 13 of private sector workers have a
pension
and while 401ks have their perks they're
just not
as stable or reliable 401ks are also
opt-in which means you aren't
automatically enrolled
left to their own devices many employees
simply aren't
saving enough if they're saving at all
of the 79
of workers eligible to save into a 401k
only 41 percent opt to participate
the national institute on retirement
security finds that the median
retirement savings balance
is just three thousand dollars for all
working age households
and a mere twelve thousand dollars for
those near retirement
most financial experts recommend a
personal retirement savings rate between
10 to 15 the real rates are between 1
and 3 the 401k was designed to be the
side dish not the main course
saddling workers with the opportunity to
manage their own retirements
has created a national crisis in
retirement preparedness
but the good news is that if you know
its place and use it wisely a 401k can
be a great part of your financial
toolkit
since pensions are going the way of the
horse and buggy you'll need your 401k to
be galloping
double time to keep from being left in
the dust take advantage of it
and you'll be riding into the sunset
instead of off a cliff
and that's our two cents
[Music]
if you've been transitioned from a
pension to a 401k
tell us about your experience in the
[Music]
comments